True. After while I got engaged.
And to say that I'm proud is an understatement.
Now, I'm not proud because she got a man to put a ring on it.
I'm proud because she's gonna have a good marriage,
because she's gonna walk the walk.
Because she found a guy who treats her like a human fucking being
and a princess. Cause that's important, too.
You see, when I talk about my happy marriage on here,
it's because I fucking locked into it.
It was a gift of cosmic proportions,
meeting the man that I married to.
I didn't have a big sister bestie like drew to tell me what, like,
a healthy man looks like or what green flags were,
or better yet, what red flags I should be watching out for. Were.
I was being raised by, like,
the early 2 ROM coms. I was raised with the,
if he's being mean to you,
he just likes you. So
I am so fucking proud
that drew is going to usher into this next generation of women,
which she already has as a single woman,
as a dating woman, and now soon to be as a married woman,
what a healthy relationship with yourself
and therefore your partner looks like.
She is going to be the big sister
to usher in a next generation of women
to know what the blueprint is supposed to look like.
And she has a platform big enough to do it.
I have always Said,
my measure of marriage success is not in the years that I married.
And the success of a relationship isn't whether or not you get engaged.
A ring on a finger means absolutely nothing
if there's no symbolism of partnership behind it.
A ring is just a ring. A ring,
a marriage is not a guarantee of commitment,
not a guarantee of happiness,
not a guarantee of compatibility and longevity in a relationship.
It's what the ring represents,
and I think drew got it right.
Congratulations to the happy couple.